[Music]
as the kardashians gear up for the
premiere of their new hulu series
they're dropping hints about if and when
they would ever quit reality tv we'll
just have to wait and see
courtney kim chloe and their famous
momager kris jenner open up in a new
interview with variety about life in the
spotlight and their decision to start a
new chapter with their show the
kardashians
can you believe this is day one
literally this is insane
when asked if they'd ever consider
living a more private life kim jokingly
refers to it as the dream and something
she might consider in 10 years
but ultimately kim tells the mag she
hasn't really thought about a life away
from the cameras
gotta love that commitment
yep meanwhile her sister courtney has a
shorter timeline in mind the 42 year old
pooch founder says she sees herself
leaving la behind in the near future
adding quote i don't think i see myself
filming on a show in five years i would
probably envision myself like just
living i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens of course fans
of keeping up with the kardashians know
that during its 20 seasons on the air
court made it known she didn't love
sharing every single detail of her
personal life on camera
i've decided to take a big step back
from filming and really
just pick and choose what i
will allow cameras to follow
yeah the push founder eventually decided
to stay on the show but cut back on what
she was willing to show on camera i'm
just
decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there but i'm not
saying goodbye
now she says the final years of filming
keeping up were really toxic for her but
insists the whole family was ready to
move on to something else
well the fam found that something else
with their new hulu series and chris she
dishes on why they decided to keep going
with another show on a different network
and it can be summed up in two little
words
cash money tune in because you never
know what's going to happen
money always matters i think that
anybody would be foolish to say that
money doesn't matter anymore
so how much money are the kardashians
making from their new hulu deal
they wouldn't say
but according to variety insiders say
their paychecks are worth nine figures
with all family members being paid
equally i love it and chloe praises her
mom for sorting out the details of the
deal saying quote she fights like a pit
bull
family's family
coco isn't making any apologies for her
hard-earned money insisting they've
earned every penny for giving up so much
of their personal lives for
entertainment quote not all money is
good money it has to be a good fit and
hulu was just the perfect fit for us
[Music]
you